all right you're done let's look at my
solution first I hope you grab the
projection from the notes since we're
populating a listview we need a weather
entry ID but since we have a join we
have to specify this ID precisely with a
table name followed by the dot followed
by the column name syntax we're not
using all of these columns but having
these constant to find will help us keep
the code compatible with the updates
we're doing in the next lessons of
course these indices are tied to our
projection if the forecast columns
changes we have to modify these
accordingly in oncreate loader we then
pass forecast columns as the projection
into our cursor loader constructor
finally we can fix up convert cursor
road to UX format within our forecast
adapter to take advantage of these
declared indices and that's it we're
done let's run it and it looks exactly
like the last time we run it it was
pretty difficult for this section but
the good news is it still working
correctly and it's a little more
efficient we're going to take more
advantage of this in lesson 5 as we make
more sophisticated user interfaces